[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey
[Music]
no i appreciate it
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
oh
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
uh
that makes sense
[Music]
[Music]
family
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
come on
um
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
how could you forget that i don't know
[Music]
congratulations
[Music]
together
[Music]
[Music]
behind yeah
[Music]
yeah let's do this more quickly
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me first unmute myself
uh good morning yo college class of
2021.
let's go
[Applause]
welcome to the graduates of grace hopper
jonathan edwards trumbull
silliman and ezra styles college
who are arrived on old campus to begin
our ceremony
and welcome to family friends and
members of the class
who are joining us virtually today via
live stream
we are so excited to have arrived on
this special day
in a few moments we will begin
announcing the graduates
as they process across the commencement
stage here in front of me
before we start our program a few words
about the land on which today's ceremony
is taking place
yale acknowledges that indigenous
peoples and nations
including mohegan mashintaka pequot
eastern pequot scattercock golden hill
pagosa
niantic and the quinnipiac and other
algonquin speaking peoples
have stewarded through generations the
lands and waterways
of what is now the state of connecticut
we honor and respect
the enduring relationship that exists
between these peoples
and nations and this land thank you and
please enjoy the program
okay mr president i have the honor to
present
candidates from trumbull college for the
bachelor's degrees
in yale college when they have been
recommended by the faculty of yale
college
and approved by the corporation dean
chun
will ask you by your official act to
confer
upon them these degrees
by the authority vested in me i
shall confer upon you the bachelor's
degrees in yale college
when designated by the dean and shall
then admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
jeffrey
joe the banner bearer of trumbull
college
claire lamarr and marcus sack the
procession marshals of trumbull college
[Applause]
a jubilee
jacob dean asher
[Music]
gianna baez
jeremy barron
sarah brakeville hackie
sam bringham
darian colby carrington
cal christophori
dale chung
caleb cohen
vinicius da silva
[Applause]
[Applause]
hannah geller
lauren gilinov
[Applause]
yashu svini jindal
zainup karajan
adia cline
hunter cohn katherine
cosey taj
phillip lakey
abigail leonard
alan liu
hannah manns
[Applause]
mitchell mayers
celia martinez
jack mattei gabriela mancillo
[Music]
rhea mattel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jonathan murillo
grant negli
obdk noram jr
max of music
[Applause]
elida orhan
[Applause]
geun park
rachira ray
[Applause]
zarya janae rogers
[Applause]
mariko fujimutu fujimoto rooks
melvin rice
[Applause]
nicolas andres ruiz widobro
magditz
[Applause]
daniel sanchez
johanna shen
jeremy robert irwin sanji
ricardo aaron soto
[Music]
[Applause]
charles tenenbaum
griffin coolidge thomas
rodney thomas ii
jared guangchan trong
peter vanderslice
ava vanick
[Applause]
anushka walia
angelica walker
[Music]
[Applause]
alexander whitaker
[Music]
adam von nikowski
christopher
eric your show
jingja jerry joe
[Music]
[Applause]
and benjamin zolkwood
congratulations trombolians murah mr
president
i have the honor to present candidates
from grace hopper college
for the bachelor's degrees in yale
college
when they have been recommended by the
faculty of yale college
and approved by the corporation dean
chun will ask you
by your official act to confer upon them
these degrees
[Music]
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer
upon you the bachelor's degrees in yale
college when designated by the dean
and shall then admit you to all their
rights
and responsibilities
[Applause]
sheldon zou the banner bearer of grace
hopper college
zhao tong chun and megan shu
the procession marshals of grace hopper
college
[Music]
malik marcain barnett
ryan elizabeth benson
alma maya bitran
sun kun yun antonio bong
timothy carter bradley
eliasar gamez ko
lin chan shin ji
chen patrick andres
cherry rachel
allegra cohen
john harmon cooper
robert sebastian crystal
[Music]
ryan ann eversole
julian matteo fernandez
[Music]
gandhi michael
edward garvey lauren
gatta zachary
jason gold vivek
gopalan
[Music]
robert james sherman howard
j.j howland
charlotte and heilinski
talis gardener ayu ayorio roneg
raeshawn antoine johnson jr
olivia danielle joraj
samuel landino sophie elle smith
morton latham paige
julia lawrence melissa
leone marlika alta gracia marceau
michael martinez
john christian beer maple
julia catherine mclellan
dalia muahlin
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
garcia zoe
elizabeth nectarline alejandro nuno
daryl luis manuel pona
[Music]
dean perseverenda
[Music]
d major roman
lyrium aviva ross
anika karina salmi
katherine wright schmeckel
[Applause]
brandon david scott
shima
kiara nicole spain
arohi srivas
simon lee stone
eric kenji takada
tiava marco torres
lynn sander
rihanna marie turner
alondra olympia vasquez lopez nancy
catherine wallicky
eric wallach
carly wana
corey wu
[Music]
amber pascal young
jordan craig young
[Music]
and the graduates who are participating
remotely
congratulations grace hopper college
class of 2021
[Applause]
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates from jonathan edwards college
for the bachelor's degrees in yale
college when they have been recommended
by the faculty of yale college
and approved by the corporation dean
chun
will ask you upon your by your official
act
to confer upon them these degrees
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon you the bachelor's degrees
in yale college
when designated by the dean and shall
then admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
anna j sun the banner bearer of jonathan
edwards college
shimasuka chica victory oba jessie
and stephen daniel orientali the
procession marshals
of jonathan edwards college
fiona eileen asbury
[Music]
et caterine bakladze
jc cacao baldomino
darnell battle
natalie beauchamp
[Applause]
griffin bowen berlin
lydia burleson
akshi chaba
simmer preet singh chada
mari makai
[Applause]
mackenzie marie cook
[Music]
caitlyn nicole corfman
catherine livingston cutler
nicholas bayard cutler jr
raji shirokay daniel
maureen donovan dustin
kent dunaway
lena h gallagher
marcos gazepis
alina jennifer mila glaubitz
mia nickay jackson
gregory johnny
kitty can anna
sophia kane
jake lawrence kaladner
matthew joseph lammerand
johnny winley
jesus daniel lee
kevin g lee
heidi mcloof charles paul
markert diego
martell samantha
jane martinelli nicholas
chandler marwell alexandra
nicole mcraven
luke ian mckenna
jillian eve mel-min
clara rose-malo
lauren moriyama
hong fu win
jesutomi odukoya
[Music]
christina beatrice otero
[Applause]
jessica taylor pavner
hoy thumb tuan bo
chofum lily cornelia
brainard rogers
calvin blake solomon
sophia suarez
alexa sabrina sai
vera jung villanueva
miles xavier waits
emma louisa wilson
why penn wong angela chao
[Applause]
alice zao
and the graduates participating remotely
[Music]
congratulations je class of 2021
mr president i have the honor to present
candidates
from silliman college for the bachelor's
degree
in yale college when they have been
recommended by the faculty of yale
college
and approved by the corporation din chun
will ask by your official act to confer
upon them
these degrees
by the authority vested in me i
shall confer upon you the bachelor's
degrees in yale college when designated
by the dean
and shall then admit you to all their
rights
and responsibilities
brooke catherine milosh the banner
bearer of silliman college
camila andrea torro and corey mark
zao the procession marshals of silliman
[Music]
[Applause]
aurora taylor as a dorian
[Music]
joke sing batra
[Music]
daniel matthew blatt
natalie jane boyer
[Applause]
emma marie brody
joseph antonio brownsberger
okay joe brenda sofia
gutierrez
chelsea maria ciao
kevin chen
[Applause]
catherine d klullo
[Music]
[Applause]
john dean
olivia drubner
farah marie emery muhammad
[Music]
[Applause]
darlene luz maria gomez
[Music]
deontay damond henson
[Applause]
samantha higgins
stephanie boma horsefall
lillian hua
jacob koppelman hut
robert william darling
brett william jewell
anthony leon g
sung me anna johnson
[Applause]
christina cowe connor
jacob kennedy j.p
kenny emery david
carrakesh
caroline kim
[Music]
lauren kim
nikita clemenco
aleen su chong ko
madelin chu kumar
stanley junlung lam
abigail vivian lee
araceli a lopez
brandon liu
thomas duke martin
[Applause]
matthew bassam massad
phyllis nohutaba p mugaza
[Applause]
gregory connor naruto
maggie k nolan
emily
samuel brooks calabrese
alice park
jordan christine pilant
william r polsky
johan popov peter prestakos
andrew james roshan
catherine jens sawkins
bavesh sandeep sayal okay
olivia shoemaker
vasilius platten siophus
slater adams smith
[Music]
kelly ann speltz
hiristo svetoslav stykov
[Music]
henry stephen suko ziemer
james gian son
martin daley tipton
teodora angiova tiankova
jenna grace vandegrift
rahm vishwanathan
aaron joshua wade
tom valenstein
kenneth wang xavier
tariq washington
thomas bailey wiesler
jason yang
[Music]
jennifer y yoon
dana zamir
and mate j lanka
the graduates participating remotely
[Music]
congratulations class of 2021.
[Applause]
mr president i have the honor
to present candidates from ezra
styles college for the bachelor's
degrees in yale college
when they have been recommended by the
faculty of yale college
and approved by the corporation dean
chan
will ask you by your official act to
confer upon them
these degrees
by the authority vested in me i shall
confer upon you the bachelor's degrees
in yale college
when designated by the dean and shall
then admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
covert james geary jr the banner bearer
of ezra styles college
gabriella blatt and luta fastdog the
procession marshals of ezra styles
college
grace ellen aronson
jacob angelo abdullah
zaineb oma winola and yola abiola
odunawo jack adam
alessandra sophia aguirre
catherine theresa erica parhamville
bessie maria bauman
brittany marie bistas sophia
eva bleak
greta kirby brown
brandon robert canfield
martin stewart chandler
[Applause]
joseph leo class alexander
nathan cohen
nathaniel alexander cuevas
[Music]
ivt duong audrey
[Applause]
ivyvictoria fan
alyssa nicole firth
veronica e galenberti
[Music]
raymond liu gao
simon alexander gabrielesis
abigail gertrude gundrum
grant theodore halliday the second
alani burnett harris
[Music]
charles townsend hardy hawkings
jacqueline de los mercedes hair perez
phillip edward hinkis
logan mclean howard
cassandra chao
catherine who alejandro antonio hocko
emily yen wen g
emily elizabeth johnson
jaeger mario johnson
darren meshach larom jones
zachary dakota jones
alicia rada kacharia
[Applause]
yuki kawamura
[Applause]
andrew peter kazimchak
joanna petrova lazarova
isabelle jin hee lee jin lee
okay emily lynn
lawrence dashow lou cameron morgan
luther
sarah jane luceriaga
sabrina liz macias
sam c manuscalco
[Music]
tia jacqueline mareska
javer coley mariwala
mary claire mcmahon britney
miranda manjavar kellen
m murman bunnell anna graves milliken
andy moe mohammed hassan mohammed
marie monroy
vikram mullick sophia
shia nam jose navas
peter necrossev max daniel noble
alexandria bella noble
corral lynn ortiz
nolan patrick padin
marissa alexis purrier
kaylee g pillinger
lorenzo penasco ferreros
andrew jordan vida prinster
ivana pristic sudjan
narayana ramanathan
astaire reyes kobe
james rizzick laurie and roe arc
carolyn elizabeth j he sacco
isabel salinas arreola
emily hope schustheim benjamin cole
shelton
javon matthew tafoya helen
s tegan
renee jessica tong zachary logan wade
[Applause]
samantha jimenez-westfall
nia aderinka whitmall
jonathan wu emily hanshu
chaithan sanjay yadav
alec gray zabornak
oasis position jen
benjamin kaihua joe
christopher zillow and the graduates
participating remotely
[Music]
go ezra styles
[Applause]
to the students of the class of 2021
and their parents families and friends
looking on
from around the globe we gather to
recognize the extraordinary
accomplishments
of all of you who have worked so hard to
complete your programs
of study we salute your efforts
your diligence your talent
and your intellect we also join you in
expressing gratitude
for all who have supported you in these
endeavors
your families and friends teachers
and other members of the yale community
congratulations class of 2021
[Applause]
wow
let's go
hello class of 2021 my name is stephen
orientale
and i am a member of the class day
committee and the senior class council
four years have gone by in the blink of
an eye
we've made so many memories from the
first year snowball fight on old campus
right here
to the yale harvard football game of
2019 where we won in double overtime
to all of the late nights whether they'd
be in the library studying for an exam
or in the common rooms talking with our
friends and suite mates
although our senior year experience was
certainly not a traditional one
the class of 2021 made the best of the
situation
when we leave yale in just a few days we
will leave
with memories and friendships that will
last a lifetime here's to the class of
2021
we did it
class of 2021 good morning my name is
stanley lamb
and i'm jin lee and we are members of
the committee
that organize class day which will air
on youtube tomorrow at 2 30 pm
two minutes before 2 30 at 2 28 pm
a special piece written by our class a
speaker robert lopez will be played from
harkness tower so keep your ears open
if you haven't already decorated a funny
hat for class day
it's not too late in fact on your seat
today you received a class day 2021 hat
that you might want to use just for that
purpose
you'll also find a gift bag which
includes items that represent
long-standing class day traditions
as well as others that are new and
unique to the class of 2021
in addition to the class day speaker
tomorrow's program also includes remarks
by members of our class
who have put together outstanding
original speeches
and because class day is about all of us
you'll see your photographs and video
reflections throughout tomorrow's
program
congratulations class of 2021 and see
you at class day
[Applause]
so
class of 2021 congratulations again
i am so happy to be with you and to
celebrate with you today
graduating is a great accomplishment uh
one of the most important ones of your
life
and if you think back to when you first
arrived on campus
no one could have imagined that you
would live through a global pandemic
before reaching this moment
but you did and thanks to your strength
and perseverance
this moment has finally come i am
honored to recognize all the work that
you have done to get here
much of it with the support of your
family and friends
so today is your day and it is theirs
too
today is a day for looking back with
pride at
everything you have accomplished and all
the goals you have reached
of course it brings some sadness too now
that you are ending your bright
college years but today is a
commencement
a beginning so now as you look to the
days and years ahead
think of the new achievements and
opportunities in front of you
and look around as well to remind
yourself of the excellent company
joining you on the new beginning your
friendships formed at yale
tomorrow you will celebrate class day a
tradition stretching back
150 years and yell college history i'm
excited to watch the virtual program
along with you
and on monday we can look forward to
president salovey's
commencement address i am grateful to
the class day committee to the senior
class council
to the university secretary's office to
your college heads and deans
and to everyone who contributed to
making the special events
of this weekend possible and i'm most
appreciative to you
for all that you have brought to yale
and will now bring out into the world
with you
again class of 2021 congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you